okay thanks yuri
for the invitation this is it's going to
be fun for me i just came from uh
i don't know if any of you were at the
the ceo of the gates foundation was here
today
speaking and she said the key to
innovating is to make sure you keep
yourself a little bit uncomfortable so
this is me being uncomfortable because
i am i haven't taken a cs class in my
life and here i am
lecturing in cs 500 or whatever this is
um so what i'll talk about today is um
sort of how at in my group and in the
center on food security we have a center
on food security environment here for
at stanford for those who didn't know
that how we're starting to think about
and now we have been thinking about
using data towards the the questions
that we have
and i'm starting with this picture which
is actually a picture of where i did
most of my work during my phd which was
let's say 10 years ago a little bit more
now and what you see here is a typical
scene in a in a developing country
especially in an area where there's lots
of active research so
i don't have a pointer i don't think but
these little
squares like you can see right above the
title there these are little
experimental plots and this is sort of
the the mo of agricultural research in
the world is
if you have a question about which which
varieties work best which practices work
best
and i'll get into a little more detail
you run it you run an experimental trial
um your sample size is typically 20 say
you replicate you know
five treatments four times or something
and you draw your conclusion and
and when i was visiting an early on in
my phd um
you know i saw these very cool things
and this was actually the the home of
norman borlaug if anyone
has anyone here heard of norman borlaug
okay so it's something to google after
uh not right now after the session
and it seemed very interesting but it
also to me seemed like a tremendous
waste because here you have thousands
and thousands of farmers all around you
performing these in in some ways
experiments but they're not controlled
experiments
and and there was no real insight being
gained from that it was all based on
this
basically very small fraction of land
where
it controlled experiments were doing so
i um
i said about during my phd trying to
understand how can we actually measure
what farmers are doing and learn more
from what farmers are doing and that
has been in some ways the story of my
career so far it has not
progressed maybe as quickly as
as a lot of applications and data
science do because collecting data in
agriculture is
and in the area of food security in
general is pretty hard so i'll talk
today
um about a few things i'm going to start
off talking just
you know assuming that you guys haven't
really thought about food scare you
probably are thinking as food security
like food contamination is that which
dharma
that's the most common question i get
food security we just mean basically you
know where your next meal is coming from
or you know that
maybe you don't know which restaurant
you're going to go to but you know that
you're going to get fed
it's it's basically the opposite of
chronic hunger or chronic insecurity
and um it's it's still a big issue in
the world and i'll talk about that a
little bit
um but but briefly and then i'll talk
about just in general terms where we see
kind of the vision of data fitting into
these these
challenges of feeding the world i'll
talk a little bit about the current
state of data
which is probably not going to impress
those of you who are used to working
with
um you know billions and billions of
data points but but it's getting there
and it's
exciting i think and then i'll talk
about some of our own research
in kind of a few examples what i'll
think of as kind of
scratching the surface of what's
possible where we do have pretty rich
data environments
what we're doing with that and um and
then i'll talk about how we're trying to
improve the richness of the data and
maybe point out some things where we
could definitely use help from
from from those of you who know more
about
data sets algorithms etc okay
so with that how do you think about food
security well i think of it really as a
three-fold challenge
and what makes it tough is is that it's
the combination of these things so the
first
element of the challenge is that we have
to produce a lot of food we have now
seven billion people in the world we're
going towards nine billion people in the
world
we have issues of resource scarcity like
groundwater depletion we have issues of
climate change
uh lots of things challenging our
ability to
keep up uh with feeding the world
and doing that at a low cost and low low
cost is really important because of the
levels of poverty in many parts of the
world it's not
always a good thing to have cheap food
right it leads to lots of waste it leads
to
obesity i'm not saying anyone here is
but uh
you know in in our community we
especially this time of year we tend to
figure out you know how do we eat less
food how do we
how do we um prevent ourselves from
taking advantage of some cheap food but
but as you i'm sure can believe this a
big deal in a lot of parts of the world
spending half your income or more on
food is is means that it's important to
keep the costs low
the second element though is that it's
really important to
engage with smallholders around the
world so you might think of a solution
why don't we just
you know make everything in go into
every community and
and bring the most advanced
sophisticated farming practices which
generally will involve mechanization and
running large units of operation
that's not going to work because most of
the poor most of the food insecure in
the world are small holders and you have
to kind of
work with them because if you're just
producing food without helping them
generate income you're not going to
solve the problem because
those are the ones who need the income
and the food to be able to be food
secure
and then finally if you were just doing
those two you might think about how to
do it by expanding land a lot
or by using lots and lots of resources
but we also want to do this in a way
that protects the environment
and this is i think well it is the
really the theme of our center on food
security and the environment it's about
meeting both of these goals
and i think one thing that people don't
quite appreciate is how in some ways how
remarkably successful
we've been in protecting the environment
in agriculture here's just a quick
kind of summary of the world in
agriculture
historically at least the last 50 years
we've more than doubled the amount of
food produced we produce over 2
billion tons of grain a year now a lot
of food
but we do that as is indicated on the
right there we've had this tremendous
increase
but 90 of that has come from the land
that was already in agriculture in 1960.
so we've been tremendously successful at
increasing the productivity of that land
which is really important because
although we've had some deforestation we
could have had far far more
deforestation
and looking forward at the at the
projected increases in demand which
range from about 50 to 100
which is why i have those two points
there so ranging from basically a
linearly
linear extrapolation to even more than
that if you
want to meet that by expanding
agricultural land you're talking about
major uh loss of native habitat
and also if you're if you're talking
about meeting that by heavily increasing
uses of water or nutrients or chemicals
you're talking about major environmental
impacts so trying to achieve those goals
using the minimum amount of land and
resources that we can is really the the
challenge
and doing that in a way that engages
smallholders and raises their incomes
and productivity that's in a nutshell
the challenge
and we still as much as we've had
success we still have a long way to go
in the sense that nearly a billion
people are chronically food insecure and
that's a very
kind of generous or let's say
conservative definition of food security
and that you have enough
to basically sit around all day if you
want to be active in any way you
actually
that number would go up quite a bit
there's a lot of inefficiencies in this
system and this
happens really in any way you look at it
but if you look at for example
how much we get out of a unit of land is
typically less than
three quarters often less than half of
what we know is possible if you manage
it really really well
and and another manifestation of that is
we know that about half of the
fertilizer applied to crops is not taken
up by the crops it's either staying in
the soil somewhere
it's it's going into the atmosphere it's
leaching into waters causing all sorts
of
eutrophication and other issues uh
groundwater contamination etc
so lots of inefficiencies in the system
and um
and this is kind of the the opportunity
here
we have lots of um big challenges lots
of current inefficiencies
um so that's kind of the the overall
challenge but what are the kind of
specific questions that we don't know
the answers to that we would like to
know the answers to
and i want to set this up as a
pretty wide range because the world of
food security the world food production
ranges
from really poor smallholder who are
really
not able to take on any sort of risk
because risk to them really means not
getting through
the year so it's very hard for them to
say make
investments in technologies that
probably will have a very beneficial
effect if there's some risk involved
all the way up to say a u.s very
sophisticated farmer who's basically
sitting in
their cab as their tractor drives itself
and is doing all sorts of
sophisticated things and he's got all
sorts of insurance backing him up
he's managing very large units of land
so the big questions in in agriculture
and in food security general um are not
the same everywhere there there's
definitely going to be
a lot of context uh dependence but
at the same time there's kind of some
commonality to the types of questions
and i would say the big
questions are generally how do you
answer a lot of little questions
and what i mean by that is if you're a
farmer for example you want to know what
crop should i be planting when should i
be planting it
what variety should i be choosing when
should i be
fertilizing what time of year how much
should i be fertilizing all of these
little questions
add up to lots of lots of decisions that
farmers are making all the time
and that's true across across the
spectrum
the other thing to to really appreciate
i think is that it's not just
farmers in the world of agriculture in
the world of food security they are
important obviously they're
they're central but there's all sorts of
other decision makers all sorts of other
people who are making decisions
that are potentially informed by data
science so for example for researchers
or companies this is more of the scale
that i interact with
um is you know in breeders they want to
know what should they be targeting what
what kind of traits would really be
useful once they get out into the
farmers fields beyond their
small experimental plots um what the
agronomists want to know is
what is what should i be telling the
farmers of how they manage should they
be
you know spacing their plants this far
apart or this far apart and they should
they be growing two
per row or three pro per roll all these
kind of very
technical type of questions um they
don't know very
good answers or they have some idea the
answers but there's lots of uncertainty
um adoption of technology is a big issue
in development in general but especially
in
in agriculture if you have a technology
you know work how do you
how do you incentivize the farmer
properly to take that up
and then at another scale you have
policy makers and policymakers
generally want to know uh what they need
to do in the short term i mean that's
kind of
the general theme of policy makers and
that can include things like
if you're in a let's say a poor african
country that's an import or a food
what does my crop look like this year
how much do i have to make sure that i
can secure on the markets
so that my people are um are fed uh
to things like in the us and the policy
makers they want to know
how should our subsidies look what
should our insurance products look like
are we
incentivizing the wrong things is there
better things that we can be doing all
these these
people have important roles to play um
and
and i think the
we interact with all of them i think
personally i interact as i said mostly
with the
people who are developing the
technologies not just the crops but all
the technologies
what's actually going to be effective
and this is something that we can help
address with
with data science so i'm going to try a
rough analogy here
just because i know that a lot of you
are familiar with all sorts of other
applications not so much agriculture
and one that yuri and i and some others
talked about a while back was was
education and the
role of data science and education so i
would say that you know
and i should say i know students prefer
not to be compared to vegetables or
or to uh or to livestock being led to
slaughter or something like that but i
think educating students is actually a
lot like growing food
in that you have lots and lots of
different factors
involved so there's all sorts of
multivariable
issues going on here that effect sizes
tend to be pretty small
for any individual factor so if you have
a small kind of trial it's very hard to
see the effects
um there's lots of ignorance about what
actually works that doesn't mean your
people won't tell you they know it works
but
there's just because of the first two
factors there's lots of uncertainty
about
what we should actually be doing and and
as a result there's lots of
um inefficiencies in the system as i
already said
because of this imperfect knowledge and
there's also a lot of heterogeneity
there's lots of variation between how it
one individual will respond to a certain
type of
instruction or or lecture or whatever
versus another one there's a lot of
difference in how a particular farmer or
a particular soil or
a particular crop will respond versus
others so there's all sorts of variation
and ideally what we would like is a
system that's very responsive
and very individualized so we would like
to
not just say this region should be
applying 100 kgs of nitrogen
and they should be planting on november
15th we would like to be able to say
well if you're in this particular
situation this soil type here's what you
should do
and try to be more nuanced or in the
case of precision agriculture which is a
term
many of you have heard what we like to
be able to say is
okay this unit of land should be getting
this go over two steps this unit of land
should be getting this
and that that those sophisticated
tractors i show you that's what they're
starting to do
but we'd like to be able to do that you
know this very small holder land versus
this very small holder land
not just having these blanket
recommendations which is pretty much how
it's done
just like in education we have sort of
best practices on average
but that misses a lot of the
heterogeneity and the other thing that i
think is very common
although maybe less common now is that
these historically have been pretty data
poor environments
and in similar ways in that they're not
necessarily that there isn't a lot of
data out there so
you know educators have records of how
well their students did
and they have some record of what they
you know how they instructed
farmers often have records of how they
did and they have records of what they
did but
it's not aggregated in any meaningful
way it's all on paper somewhere or it's
in somebody's computer but
because of privacy concerns or just
because of technological issues
people like me researchers or policy
makers are generally working in a data
poor environment historically but that
but that's changing
so i'm gonna i'm going to probably over
use this analogy as we go through but
that's that's sort of a
comparable situation i would say
now the current state of data in in the
world of food
varies a lot across the spectrum as you
can imagine so on the right end of the
spectrum the most sophisticated farmers
are generally right now keeping very
detailed records both about what they're
doing
and about what the productivity of their
systems are on a
meter-by-meter basis in some cases
that's sort of the one end of the
spectrum
the other end of the spectrum and
actually most of the spectrum is
is a far cry from that and to give you a
sense of that i'm going to show
some data from somewhere very close to
here in kenya which is
a colleague here marshall burke has
worked a long time in and this is just
some
survey data so the general way that
people collect data in these systems is
to go out and ask farmers about
what they've been doing and what they've
been producing and this shows you what
they report in terms of production
for their field so this would be in this
case how many bags how many 90 kilogram
bags did you produce in your field
and what you should notice here is that
this is a very lumpy
histogram and it's not that just
magically they all
happen to produce exact increments of
bags is that they are really rounding
off
to the nearest hundred kgs which is can
be a lot
not only that but they are then when you
ask them how much areas
is are they producing this on again it's
very it's very um
rounded okay so this is if you add these
two together and you're trying to
measure something like productivity per
unit of land
what you get is in this case a very
fuzzy view of what's actually going on
on these individual fields
and you get that only for this sample
that you spent a lot of time and effort
going to collect and it may be
representative of some small region but
it's not something that
is generally done in a very repeated
fashion um
in most places so it's it's very
difficult and it doesn't it's not just
um i've been talking a little bit about
yields or a lot about yields because
that's kind of what i work on
but there's other important aspects of
food security that are very poorly
measured
so very closely related to productivity
would be the prices of food in the
markets
especially in these poor areas where
there's not a whole lot of
interaction with the global markets
prices can really fluctuate a lot and
we really have a very poor understanding
of how much they fluctuate the local
scale
we often only have that understanding
several weeks or months after these
fluctuations happen and that's a big
deal if you're trying to target
assistance and
and help avoid food insecurity at the
same time we really would like to know
what are the assets involved at the
household level how much
do people have so that you can target
assistance in the right ways people who
have assets you can try to
promote or offer things that require a
little risk but but probably have a lot
of return
we're people where where people are
really poor like if anyone's heard of
give directly
you would try to just do something like
unconditional
cash transfers where you just basically
drop cash in in the village or in the
household
based on understanding of what the
assets are but that requires
understanding
um where people are rich where people
are poor where they have assets and
that's
all these things are very poorly known
they tend to be known only in cases
where we've done very
slow and expensive ground surveys things
that i generally don't have the patience
to do although
i realize how important they are
okay so then that's sort of the current
state of data
in general but i'll talk um i'll talk
more specifically about how that's
changing in recent years and what we're
doing with them
um okay so back to the analogy so what
are we hoping to do i think we're hoping
to do
basically the same things that we're
hoping to do in education or at least
that what people tell me they're hoping
to do in education
um is to be able to very quickly
identify when something works
so you can see this whether well ideally
you're doing some sort of randomized
intervention that is very easy to see
cause and effect
but even without that you can quickly
see when performances are increasing and
what factors were associated with that
you can try to individualize things much
more better
much more better as i said before you
can try to
basically reverse all the inefficiencies
that we talked about before and also you
can have a much better
idea of how things are changing over
time so that you can either understand
what's working but also so that you can
again target interventions and there's
all sorts of interventions in the world
food security
on the one end there's the food a that
you see when there's big crises but that
there's a whole spectrum all the way to
what i was talking about with
um cash transfers trying to lift people
out of poverty
okay and and so basically this is what
we're trying to do in agriculture
um and in food security is very very
comparable
okay so moving on now i want to give you
a sense of what can be done
when you have um fairly big data sets
and the
example i'll use is from
the recent some recent studies we've
done so we've done a series of studies
in different settings with different
data sets
um but i would say this represents kind
of the biggest
of the big data sets that we've worked
with this is a uh animation here
of some uh field level insurance records
that we were able to obtain
through a collaboration with the usda so
what farmers are
are yielding on their individual fields
so each of these individual points
is an individual field in the three
states of iowa
illinois and indiana over time you can
see the tremendous variation that exists
both across the
region and over time um
i mean we see variation in colors but
how what's the difference i'm sorry yeah
the scale is not there this is this is
the extent of my um visualization
capability here
uh the the reds are high yielding areas
and the blues are low yielding areas and
there's about a factor of two difference
between the highest and the lowest
yeah thanks hector so generally iowa
uh is is pretty pretty high yielding
generally some of these southern parts
of illinois and indiana are less but you
can see
lots of variation space and time lots of
richness here
so anyone who drives through the midwest
thinks
gosh this is the same thing over and
over and over again i drive miles and
all i see is the same thing
there's actually a lot of richness there
that your eye isn't quite sensitive to
because once a cornfield gets pretty
good
it's really hard to see the difference
between a really good and a really
really good corn field
but but there is actually tremendous
amount of difference
okay so we can do various things
depending on what other types of data
sets that we have
so one of the questions that i mentioned
or or one of the communities that i
mentioned are breeders and what breeders
really want to know
uh in in respect to climate change is do
they need to do anything differently are
there certain traits that would be
useful
or becoming more useful that they should
really have their eye on and one way to
look at that is to try to look at what
are the weather
characteristics that really drive
variation in yields
seems like something we should have
figured out like 2 000 years ago
in terms of we know rain is good right
you hear lots of things about rain being
good
but we want to be more sophisticated now
we want to know in a very quantitative
way which factors are most important
what you know what specific factors what
specific time of years
so we can piece together lots we have
lots of good graded weather data in the
u.s
station data that can be gridded all
sorts of different variables this is
just one
uh one particular illustration of just
how we compare these data
this is a this is the entire data set
now plotted with a with the lowest fit a
mean fit to it
just for two variables that emerge as as
fairly important
um the first being high daytime
temperature so t-max is basically the
hottest part of the day
what's the average hottest part of the
day in this window of about july when
the
corn plant is flowering and what you can
see is that there's a lot of scatter of
course
but you see a general tendency towards a
negative effect as you get hotter
and then you see things really falling
off as you get really hot
right hopefully you're convinced of that
what you see with with rainfall which is
interesting and not surprising is that
you do get as you get more rainfall
during this window it does help you
but it only helps you up to a point and
the magnitude of the effect
is not nearly as big and this is this
was kind of a surprise because this is a
rain-fed agricultural system there's no
irrigation going on
you would expect rainfall to be really
the key but what really matters in this
system these are deep soils that
generally are replenished over the over
the winter
rainfall in the season is important it's
not trivial but as long as it's not too
low
what really matters is how fast are they
burning through that sore of water and
how fast they burn through that water
is really a function of how hot the
hottest parts of the day are
the the amount uh the ability of of the
air to
suck up water you can think of is really
non-linear with temperature that's why
this this feature emerges
so so on the left not to be
contradicting you but
the blue is is the intensity of the
number of points right
if you hadn't shown that red line and
you would ask me to guess i would have
said it's random
i mean it doesn't i don't see well a lot
of correlation
it seems like so there's probably two
things going on there one is that
there could have been a better color
scheme to illustrate the density of
points
the other is probably that our eyes are
never as good as as uh
we think they are in terms of picking
out these patterns so these are you know
these are robust by any measure that you
look at in terms of how
these lines emerge and one one thing we
do to look at that is we do more formal
models than just these bivariate plots
so one thing we do is these
multivariate regression splines this um
this is actually a technique i learned
when i was a graduate student here in in
jerry friedman's course but i'm sure
it's kind of passe now but
they're still quite powerful in
agriculture because what these do is
they
allow you to evaluate the data
evaluate asymmetries in the data
um in terms of for example with high
daytime temperature we
often use something called vapor
pressure deficit which is really a
function of high daytime temperature
um allows you to pick up asymmetries and
non-linearities like that
it also does a very good job of parsimo
parsimonious
variable selection so this kind of data
set was useful
in the context of all this other weather
data that we had in in trying to
identify
what actually drives variation in this
system and in some ways it's a bit
surprising compared to what
people kind of thought based on the
limited amount of data that have been
used before them
another thing we've done with this data
set is combine it with
another nice product that's been coming
online recently which is
the usda uses some satellite data to map
which crops are growing in which fields
and obviously with the data we had we
know
if they're reporting a corn yield we
know that that field had corn but what
this allows us to do is go what did that
field have in the year prior and what
did it have in the year prior
and actually in agriculture a lot of the
there's a lot of
important effects of how you of what
your cropping history is there's a lot
of uncertainty about how important that
is but there's a lot of evidence that
rotating is a big benefit because of all
sorts of reasons one is that the crops
will be
basically exploring different parts of
the soil profile so they'll be getting
nutrients and water from different
parts another big one is that they are
prone to different pests and weeds
so that a pest that does really well on
one crop if you break it with another
crop
it won't be there as much the next year
so uh one of the issues is
that because the price of corn has been
going up at least until this year
there's been a tendency towards
not rotating even though it's kind of
well understood that in general people
should rotate
so this just shows from usda some
statistics about the the rate of
corn on corn has gone from about 10 to
15 percent
and some of the farmers will tell you
that's because they can manage around
this
penalty it requires a little bit better
management but it's not that hard to
grow corn on corn
um another issue in this though is that
a lot of the insurance products are
actually
uh and they're not actually
incentivizing at all rotation they're
just ensuring corn if you're growing
corn
regardless of what your history is so if
the price of corn is higher you're going
to be that much more likely to go for
corn
so what we've done is piece together a
history of rotation
compared it to these nice yield data
sets we have and start to look at
what are the actual benefits of
different types of rotations so you can
look at
corn yields following soybean you can
look at soybean following corn you can
look at
corn following wheat following soybean
different different combinations as you
can imagine
with a large data set i'll show you here
just some
initial results of corn after
soybean versus corn after corn so this
is just a difference
shown here by state and by year just to
give you a sense of the heterogeneity
and what you can see is a couple of
things one is that there is this on
average this very strong benefit
on the order of say 10 or 5 bushels per
acre
to give you a sense average productivity
in these systems will be about 200 so
that's on the order of three to five
percent and in agriculture three to five
percent is not a small
a small deal especially in if you think
of their margins being small that extra
three to five percent is a big deal
um and you can see so that average
effect you can also see lots of
heterogeneity
and this heterogeneity can be explained
by things like
how stressful was the environment that
year we know that or we see
at least that rotations tend to be a
bigger benefit when you're getting very
stressed
maybe because of those dynamics i
mentioned before with pests or with
water
you can see things that are a bit
surprising that you know in terms of
which soils
are are not favored by rotation so these
are the kind of questions that we're
looking at now
i'm gonna skip that for a time okay so
now here's what i really wanted to talk
about which is where things are headed
and where um and where we you know are
eager to engage with
uh with you guys and others um so there
i
the way i think of it and and this could
be totally wrong is that there's
basically two approaches out there to
try to get data rich
in the sense of trying to get towards
where you can do really good things with
data
one is you scale up ways of existing
ways of
or you find new ways of actually
directly measuring what it is you want
to measure
and i think in education like the moocs
would be a good example of this you're
you're measuring directly you know the
performance of the students on what you
want them to perform on
an example in the world of food security
is is a startup called premise.com which
is actually using smartphones around the
world to just
take pictures of the prices of foods at
markets and they're tagged with the
location and the time and you can begin
to put together a sense of what the um
what the prices are uh but the other way
you can do it is try to be clever about
using proxies that are not
directly what you want to know they're
probably imperfectly or or
very maybe even poorly related to what
you want to know but there is some
predictive power
and that gives you the ability to get
lots and lots
of data with some error which is a lot
better than a little bit of data without
error
uh the problem is though if we're in
such data poor environments it's hard to
actually even test or calibrate these
approaches and so
we've had we've struggled over the years
thinking about how do you find good
proxies when you can't really test them
that well
it's actually quite hard to publish in
the scientific literature if you say we
came up with a new way of measuring
something
for example in india we did a lot of
remote sensing i'll show you in a second
of yields getting actual good field
measurements of yields in india
for enough of a of a sample and number
of years to be convincing is actually
quite difficult
and when you do get the data you don't
necessarily believe it
okay so uh a few examples not from my
work but to give you a sense of it
of this proxy approach mobile phones are
now being looked at
as a way of tracking food security or
food consumption at least
and they've done studies in different
countries of africa with getting data
from mobile phone providers
looking at the top-up
amounts the amount people are adding to
their phone
in a given month and then doing detailed
surveys about what they're consuming in
that month and they find that at least
over
space across different people and across
different villages you get pretty good
correlations between your
top-up expenditures and the consumption
of more
the uh the the high-end or nutritious
food that's kind of a sign
of food security and these correlations
are giving you a sense of what those
look like
so that's definitely an encouraging
thing using just information on mobile
phones themselves or from the providers
to try to track it's still an open
question whether this actually provides
an ability to track over time but at
least now it's using it's being used to
look at
whether it can at least pick up spatial
differences
another thing that's been really played
with a little bit but i think has a lot
of potential is using social media like
twitter
to try to track things like food prices
um
i can imagine that this could be used
for lots of things other than food
prices
um in in the obviously it is in general
but in the world of food security
things like um bad weather events that
we don't really have good data
on either because it's a place that's
not really well measured
um or there's like a hail storm that
comes through a very narrow area
but in this context they're looking for
example in indonesia
at the incidence of prices price
increases in the price of rice and
tweets about
i don't know whatever words you would
search for you know this more than i but
you can imagine there are things that
would be associated with
with complaining about that so that's
another element then the big one that
that i've been focused on
is using satellites so there are there
are satellites
acquiring data up the wazoo now as you
know
but even going back historically there's
lots and lots of data
and what's nice about that is even as i
mentioned even in the us
where we have really good data now being
collected not necessarily shared but at
least collected by farmers we don't
actually have it going back two decades
but
if we can figure out a good way to use
satellites we can actually get a really
rich history that we can look at
and you can look at lots of things so
you can look at crops maybe that's
obvious you can see some crops there
maybe more clearly
but as i'll talk about in a bit you can
also look at all sorts of features of
the landscape besides the crops that
might be indicative
of the level of assets in a community
and there's all sorts of assets that we
would be
interested in this is the the high
resolution kind of realm of things
uh you can tell what crop it is from
those images or
well this is this is one of the
questions is can you tell what crop it
is
can you tell how productive that crop is
so that's what i'm going to be talking
about
okay as i said decades of past imagery
which is a nice
addition because we can't really go back
in time on a lot of the social media or
other things
the other thing that's really exciting
is a lot of this at least coarser level
data is becoming not only
acquired but it's becoming freely
available um it's
spanning more wavelengths so radar is
really useful if you're trying to see
through clouds especially
in poor areas the eu has a new
a new constellation that's going to
include a lot of radar data that's
being acquired at 30 meter resolution
and provided for free
thermal data can be really useful as
well and
as i just said it's useful for all sorts
of things but i'll talk mainly about
yields
um and it's and it's not easy let me
just kind of summarize my thing it's not
easy because we don't have a lot of
ground truth
but what we've developed over the last
few years
is a way of of trying to train
algorithms without ground data and the
way we do this is to try to basically
simulate
hypothetical landscapes pretend that
we're looking at those as if they're
real ants or look at those as if they
were real landscapes
train our algorithms and then apply
these algorithms to the actual data
so i'm sure there's lots of examples of
this
but in other fields i'm actually not
sure of that but i think
it's something i picked up along the way
i don't know exactly where
but what we do is we run crop model
simulations
and then so a crop model simulation just
to explain a little is you have
a crop growing each day it gets rain or
it sees sunlight and it gets a certain
temperature and all the dynamics that we
understand about crop growth
and we don't understand those perfectly
as i said but it's captured in the model
to some extent
and a crop grows over the over the year
and it yields something at the end of
the year
and then what we can do is at each point
in time we can look at the model and say
okay what does a crop in the model look
like so let's say it has a leaf area of
three that's a unit that we often use
which is to say if you collapse the crop
down to the ground how thick would
how many leaves would you have per unit
area that's a good measure of biomass
and what we know is that there's a very
well-known well-understood relationship
between say the greenness of a plant
and what it looks like from space and
this just gives you a sense
of a vegetation reflectance spectrum so
as a function
of wavelength here's our visible
wavelengths here so
plants are green you guys all know that
um but then what happens is after they
absorb red light in the near future they
get very reflective and
so we often use near-infrared versus red
or versus some
normalizing wavelength as a measure of
plant biomass because plants are so
reflective
much better it much easier to see
variation in the near infrared
than if you're driving by in a car for
example and so
on there's been empirically evaluated in
lots of different settings this is just
a plot on the right
of leaf area versus a measure of
greenness which is basically
ratios of of this band 4
which is a landsat terminology but this
set of wavelengths here to this set of
wavelengths here
landsat i should just say right now is
is kind of the main workhorse
historically of
of land remote sensing because the usgs
has been putting up these satellites
since the late 70s
there's lots and lots of historical data
and
it's very useful for vegetation because
of this big contrast
across the wavelengths that they measure
and and the other thing about landsat is
it was
a while ago now made freely available
recently has been
and i'll talk about this in a second has
been all ingested into google's earth
engine and so we're using that now as a
way of rapidly going through the entire
archive of landsat data
so this is just a visual of what we do
we simulate a particular field in a
particular year with a particular
management system
and then we do that and we get a final
yield and then we do that lots and lots
of times so this just shows you some
selection of the of the population we
have in our in our
sim world here lots of variation in all
sorts of factors
this would be like what is actually
varying when you're looking at a new
scene
from from field to field or from scene
to scene and then what we do is we
will then say okay what is the data we
actually have in terms of satellite data
and weather data and go in and try to
look at this data set and say okay if we
could observe say at these two dates
what would be our algorithm or what
would be our regression basically to
predict
yields from what we can observe and so
we do
we build right now we're just building a
multiple linear regression where you
have interactions between weather
and reflectance and that's useful for
reasons having to deal with the fact
that
how you interpret whether let's say a
very green canopy in the beginning of
the season
whether you interpret that as a really
good thing or not for yield depends on
what you know about what the weather has
been what the weather will be
because of the dynamics of crop growth
you don't want to run out of water at
the end of the year for example
so if you get a really dry year having a
really green
uh field in the beginning the year
wasn't such a good idea
uh so we build these regressions i'm not
going to get into the details of the
regressions what i'll talk about is
is some empirical testing of these
approaches
um and the nice thing is here you can
you can swap in any sort of sensor
as long as you have a relationship
between what you're measuring with the
sensor and what kind of
ground biophysical measurement you're
trying to make so here's kind of an
early prototype of this that we
developed in mexico a while back
showing you uh wheat yields in a in this
is actually
the the satellite view of that picture i
showed you in the opening slide
and you can see uh we yield estimates
here i do have a scale for you
it's about a factor of two again red is
high yields blue is low yields
um and that's uh comparison with farmers
we were able to get accurate data
from a well-defined area that we can
compare with the satellite data
so this was i think a demonstration that
you can do a pretty good job of it
uh and then we went on to apply this in
lots of different um
enviro cases i i'm not gonna go through
them because i don't wanna
basically this is just more of what i
was talking about before about how these
can be useful this is in india for
example
where we got to understand that distance
from roads the distance from technical
advisors wasn't as important
really at all as compared to something
like distance to the water source
but uh that's not what i really want to
focus on so we um
we now can scale this up so we were
doing this on a case-by-case kind of
site-by-site basis
now we can really scale this up with
earth engine how many of you have heard
of earth engine
just show of hands okay how many of you
have heard google right you've heard of
google
okay they they're good with data they've
developed this platform for working with
all sorts of gridded data products and
that is actually
started as our contribution to
deforestation monitoring but it's now
expanding
uh and we've been using this
implementing our algorithms in earth
engine so that we can scale up and this
is just showing you
some initial tests we've done in these
three states i was showing you the data
for
before so the idea is here to test it
where we're data rich where we actually
have something to test against
but then to scale it so that we can
apply it in all parts of the world in
all
crops and different places now
whether you're impressed with so these
are the comparisons of what we're
estimating
versus what we're observing and since i
can only reach this one i'll talk about
this one
because it looks pretty good too we do
we do a decent job
whether you look at this and say that
you could do much better or
or it's good depends i think on the
application and i tend to think of
as i said before lots of data of
mediocre quality is really powerful okay
that's kind of i would say
one of the models of data science in
general so i'm very pleased when i see
um some correspondence agronomists look
at this and say oh your r squares are
not 0.95 how could you ever
how could you ever use this but i think
that's their problem in terms of
understanding the the power of what
we're doing
or what the data science can do so i
would say overall this gets a passing
grade um it's
it's really early days so we haven't
even for example correctly filtered out
the clouds yet this is one of the things
i'll mention is actually
filtering out clouds is not so hard
filtering out cloud shadows is something
that
um the community is still struggling
with and if you want to really scale up
and you're in places that have clouds
because they're growing crops and
they're getting rain
it can be an important thing to filter
our cloud shadows
okay so that um and i just want to talk
a little bit about extension of that not
just spatially but into other
sensors and it's fairly trivial from
from a standpoint of swapping in one
center for another but what it really
transforms is our ability to look at the
poorest places in the world
because historically we've had landsat
data which is shown on the right here
for
for that area of kenya which i showed
you a picture of on the ground before
whereas you need really something like a
one meter resolution data to really be
able to pick out individual fields
individual houses
and what how many of you have heard of
skybox is another survey
question okay skybox is now actually
been acquired by google but
they have a new approach to acquiring
very high resolution data more cheaply
and they've got this great skybox for
good program which we've been able to
engage with where they are providing
data for
you know philanthropic opportunities
this shows you burning man
in last summer and skybox just
illustrating their ability to
repeatedly get very high resolution
measurements they can basically target
over multiple days and their
constellation is growing there's there's
other people in this
space as they say so the there's an
explosion especially of high resolution
satellite data
and that's exciting from our standpoint
because we can now go into places
where we have actual some ground data
and start testing and these are four
places that we've been
um we're starting to acquire through
skyvox through their skybox for good
program that we're excited about
and each of these we have different um
uh
collaborators that are doing very
detailed crop cuts or surveys that we
can compare
you wanted me to stop five after right
that's all right okay
so good so i only have a couple minutes
so just in terms of what we are
kind of doing over the next year or so
is back to the analogy with with
education so with these moocs you have
this great opportunity to randomize
interventions and that
brings a lot of power in terms of
advancing knowledge or understanding of
of what works in agriculture we it's
still an outdoor sport so we can't
kind of i mean there are robots involved
but there still is a lot of
um things that we can't very easily
monitor and get instant feedback on but
what we can do is partner with people
who do randomize trials
there's in the development community
there's all sorts of people doing
randomized trials and
really monitoring impact is one of the
big costs of those tiny houses so with
with more kind of satellite-based or big
data-based approaches to monitoring
impact at the field level it really
enables this
in kind of the same way that moocs
enable randomized trials in education
but not quite
the yeah i'll skip this merging of of
different types of data with
different types of satellite data with
some of the other data sets is going to
be
a focus and then i think in the kind of
medium term to long term what we'd like
to do is be able to
leverage this existing or this initial
data sets that we can
to try to attract the farmers and then
get all sorts of more information from
them
that we can't hope to get otherwise so
last slide um
or yes less light is um just kind of on
the specifics of what are we in fsc
actually looking for excited students or
faculty to engage on
one is this issue of assets so we have
some places where we have actually good
information
on all sorts of things of descriptors of
household assets including things like
the household size and the roof type
and there's been some initial work in
different places about how well can you
actually
automate an algorithm to go through this
high resolution date and pick that up
um stefano iran i don't know if he's
here but he's um
he's one person that we're looking to do
this but we're we're he
he and us are looking for good students
to engage on that um and it doesn't have
to just be ruse i
you know if you get repeated
measurements you can things see things
like livestock potentially moving around
which is
livestock is one of the big assets in
it's it's livestock
smart algorithms for cloud shadow
detection
we and i've talked to yuri about this a
little bit we're really
um extremely novice at using
some of the data sources that you guys
are very experienced using so i think
that's a big opportunity because again
we do have
in certain places some some pretty nice
data sets on
things like local market food prices or
local assets
and then finally those of you who are
into the world of developing apps i
think a really nice app would be one
that
very quickly interacts with all of the
free imagery that's available now maybe
with some of the algorithms on top of
them to interpret them
and then uses that as a form for getting
more data from farmers so that we can
get to this point
where we have massive data sets to work
with i think like in all areas of data
science privacy is always going to be an
issue
but i think in the long term the
benefits are just going to be
justifying the the types of personal
risk that people might see
at least i could speak for myself i'm
not using any of this data for any means
other than research but
um i can understand the concerns there
but i think um
uh you know the potential there for
getting data
is is enormous and we should really take
advantage of that if we can
so that's 505 or 506 and i'm happy to
take questions
thanks
so we have type of questions yeah
yeah so i i read a lot about monsanto
and how terrible they are and you know
and what they're doing
so what is the influence of capitalism
and western companies to food security
in third world countries positive
negative what's the
okay so i i think that
it it depends very much i think that a
lot of these companies are really
getting much better about partnering in
these countries often licensing their
products for free
helping researchers get trained so
there's lots of positives there
and i and i think as these markets
emerge there's real business
opportunities for these companies to
engage in and the private sector is you
know it's so essential in
a especially in a field where you got
thousands and thousands of individuals
involved that scaling up in the public
sector is really just
impossible so you really need the
private sector and i think
peop groups like monsanto or dupont or
syngenta
they're doing all sorts of good things
um
there's just a more general issue here
of of the
um i guess the favorable environment
in in the rich world in terms of
investing in agriculture
in terms of policies that favor
agriculture or help support it
that you get um into arguments about you
know is the gap just widening and
whining is hard for the
the developing world to keep up but i
would say that you know
certainly don't believe everything you
read when it comes to um
these countries uh these companies and
acting in different countries but
there's
there's always going to be heterogeneity
and what the impacts are so it's a kind
of a bland answer but
they are helping to push data science
forward
they are helping to conquer some of
these privacy concerns that are going to
be an issue to tackle at some point so
that's all for the positive
um and hopefully they use it very wisely
and
don't don't cause trust to be lost
in 20 years time when you have this
product and you want to give it to
smaller followers
what is the conduit going to be i mean
how you mentioned sort of the
distortionary impact of insurance ideas
i wonder if you see like
policy changes players like monsanto or
any other
well in terms of you know i have little
doubt that
in 10 years time smartphones are going
to be ubiquitous
even to the poorest level of the poorest
farmers so that kind of direct conduit
i think there's already examples of that
for example in india there's this great
ngo that has started basically filming
farmers to make videos to instruct other
farmers it's like a peer-to-peer
training service
and this is taken off and partly because
it's surprising how much access the
poorest farmers have to
to these digital mediums
you know as i always said to the last
answer i think the private sector
at some level has to be involved for
scaling up and that's you know this is
going to have to be a profitable
enterprise
but um beyond that i don't know i mean
it's a it's a good question
i think
i think there's just huge opportunity so
i don't know how it's going to shake out
what effect do you think
great question some questions about
drones and you know that that's kind of
a
question about picking winners in the
sense of there's lots of
great ways to acquire data that are all
getting better at the same time
so you've got these nano satellites or
micro satellites that you're
dropping by an order of magnitude the
cost of satellite data
but drones are getting much cheaper as
well and then you have all sorts of
ground-based sensors that have
opportunities so sticking in say a soil
moisture probe
or doing some sort of ground-based kind
of radar measurement or something like
that
these are all progressing uh
if i had if i had to pick a winner right
now
you know i guess i'm i'm from the
satellite camp in in general
just because of the scalability and the
and the um
i think there'll be all sorts of kind of
privacy
issues with drones as much as or if more
than with satellites but
no i'm excited about drones i think in
in the bay area what you're seeing is
lots of drone based um
work right now because the satellites
aren't quite there in terms of what
they're measuring how many sensors you
can put up there right now the
the micro satellites that i talked about
that are cheaper are measuring very
basic stuff like
red and near for a reflectance whereas
drones are measuring thermal
um all sorts of they're doing lidar
they're doing fluorescence
so there'll be always be a niche for
that but i think eventually those will
all be
in space as that technology gets better
assuming there's not too much space that
people start here
yeah assuming you like perfected all the
data
collection technology like what is the
magnitude of improvement
and efficiency in agriculture like the
maximum yeah it's a great question and
it's one that i
ask myself and my students all the time
which is kind of the scariest questions
like what if this all works then what
um and you've seen a lot of the
discussion in i don't know if you read
the economist or wherever when they're
talking about monsanto and their new
play on data
they're saying that they could get five
percent yield gains
and that's a guess i think
my sense is that it depends where you
are so
my sense is that in the rich world what
you're going to get is not so much the
yield benefits as the input savings
that most farmers in the rich world are
kind of risk averse on the side of
losing yield
and so they actually apply lots of
inputs to ensure that they get pretty
high yields although there still are
lots of losses so i think there is maybe
a five percent yield gain
but what the real benefits will be is
that there'll be 20 or 30 percent
reductions in the amount of inputs of
fertilizer for example
and those will have huge cost savings
and huge environmental benefits as much
as
productivity gains but if you go and
then if you go to like the china's and
the indies of the world
it's it's both it's there's huge waste
of inputs but there's also huge
yield losses as well they're basically
just on a trajectory that takes a little
while
and i think the opportunity there is
huge in both cases in the um in the
poorest parts of the world
you know i don't think it's too much to
say that well
i mean i think it's clear agronomically
you could double or triple yields
but whether data science is going to be
the
critical factor in making that happen i
don't know you'll notice in my title i
said why data science might help view
the world
and it's because i'm not a good salesman
i guess but i think that
you know it's an open question still but
my experience has been that
anytime i present a good data set
there's in an agricultural audience
there's five ways people think to use it
that i haven't thought of and so
kind of in principle i'm optimistic and
if you look at the just the amount of
waste that goes on the amount of yield
losses that go on
all of that is in the farmers interest
to avoid
and and i think with good financing
models maybe with providers that come in
i think that data could play a huge role
in both targeting things and then also
understanding just what should we be
doing in these systems we don't have
the history of agricultural research
experiments in in africa
say that we have in the u.s so there's
all sorts of opportunity
but that's a long-winded shrug at your
answer like i don't i don't really know
it's a great question though can you
tell from the analytics
satellite data from the first question
whether they were genetically modified
crops being used
or not that's such a big european versus
now this issue
yeah you know genetically modified crops
are used quite a lot they're about 15
of the crop land in the world they're
used actually
even more in developing countries than
in develop but they're used widely
and whether in terms from a data science
perspective
you know what's the overlap between
genetic innovations and data science
innovations
and i think they're kind of orthogonal
but there are some
synergies in the sense that as we
identify very
specific niches for certain traits with
data science
that genetic techniques kind of open up
the possibility of doing that much more
cost effectively
possibly so so genetic modification you
know is
and i'm maybe you've had talks from
biologists they're definitely in a big
data science world themselves in terms
of searching for
like the genomic patterns that associate
with things that are favorable
so certainly data science within genetic
modification is a big thing but whether
what i'm talking about here which is
really looking at agronomy and
management of crops relative to the
choice of genetically modified crops
whether there's an interplay there i'm
not not sure
let's take one more student or yeah go
ahead
hey um so you mentioned that there's a
lot of satellite data from like america
going back
like several decades um that's around
the world sorry it's an american
satellite that they've been acquiring
from around the world okay got it um so
i'm curious as to whether it's possible
to use you know insights from like
decades ago uh even though there's been
like a lot of change in the environment
like climate change and things like that
yeah still validated
yeah so there's there's this co uh trade
off you go back further in time you're
less and less relevant
for today so it you know it depends on
the application i think for things like
understanding crop rotations getting a
nice five-year history
is enough and that's really useful um
for things though like understanding
where should we be targeting
interventions
to improve soil or to avoid degradation
of soil
that you need kind of a longer term
understanding of what's going on
and i think that's that's an example
where you
you would benefit from the longer time
horizon there's also big questions that
we
are interested in in terms of how how
much is it really
the farm itself and the farmer itself um
and if you can look over a long period
of time you can really get a sense
just like if you look at a mutual fund
manager over one year
you know they could do really well one
year they might even do really well over
three years but if you have a 10 year
history you can really
start to understand the role of luck
versus the role of skill and how much we
should expect
skill to improve things because a lot of
this data science is about getting more
skill
and if you have a sense looking over
time how important skill is
you can get a sense to answer this
question that was asked about that so
there are there are roles but your point
is exactly right which is that
you don't want to go back to 1970 and
and think that you're studying
current crops current techniques let's
thank the speaker again
you